are you ready to catch them all again
Pokemon Sun and Moon takes us to the
all-new a lolla region which looks an
awful lot like the Hawaiian island Oahu
it's packed with new starters
legendaries and gym leaders hopefully
you've got your 3d or 2d s handy because
it's coming this fall Pokemon Sun and
Moon releases November eighteenth thanks
to a new trailer we've gotten our first
look at Sun and Moon starter Pokemon
there's rowlett a flying grass-type owl
Lytton a fire-type cat and pop Leo a
water-type seal as usual they're all
uniquely adorable the trailer also gives
us a glimpse at the new legendaries sons
is a powerful-looking lion and moons is
some sort of majestic bat we don't know
what they're called but they definitely
look cool Sun and Moon marked the
seventh generation of Pokemon games
thanks to Pokemon bank support you'll be
able to move your collection from red
blue yellow alpha sapphire Omega Ruby x
and y all the way up to the latest
versions we don't have to wait much
longer to play sun and moon but if you
want to catch all the details about the
upcoming games keep it locked at
gamespot